ich bin ins theater gefallen und die
zahnbürste auszupacken
wo zur hölle fange ich da nur eigentlich
ist alles damit gestartet das sich
plötzlich einen anruf von nils also vom
wheels der nils bekommen habe ich hatte
schon immer diese unsere agentur
aufgenommen wird ist alles umgestellt
und fake ist und man könnte deshalb
vielleicht eventuell mit creator
irgendwie aller kelly oder so was machen
aber wenn ihr bei ich hab meine finger
nicht im spiel
außerdem ist für uns beide dann komplett
safer deswegen was geiles zusammen
machen wollen sie mit zwei tage später
wieder in dem telefonat gelandet in dem
wir besprochen haben was wir jetzt alles
braucht eine fake agentur mit einem fake
nahm und einer domain noch frei ist
agentur für online marketing social
media so jung und frisch aus
berlin-mitte ich kann die club mate
flaschen bis hierhin zwischen man kennt
das ja mittlerweile entlassenen leiter
uhr 1 kommentar wenn ich mich
unterstützen wollt natürlich musste ich
um das ganz real wirken zu lassen nicht
nur eine website bauen sonne mir auch
cases ausdenken um die website zu füllen
und so zu tun als hätten wir schon
geisteskranke kampagnen auf die beine
gestellt weekday the wall street 2 und
eine imaginäre liquid firma oben drauf
und fertig ist unsere agentur mit
oder aber natürlich brauchen wir noch
ein produkt mit dem wir die leute dann
im endeffekt ops nehmen könnten ein
produkt das extrem scheiße ist aber
genau nicht so scheiße dass die leute
nicht bereit werden ist für eine menge
geld zu machen mit zahnbürste könnte
dabei eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren
wie würde ich jetzt gerne hoch halten
aber ich habe natürlich wieder schlecht
geplant bisher habt keinen schutz haben
bis in hand produkt kaufen produktbilder
machen mail schreiben mit dem management
auseinander setzen und hoffen dass
irgendjemand von den bereit das zu
unserem meeting zu kommen tatsächlich
bekomme ich antworten wie kelly und
sandra sagen für eine agentur gespräch
zu vieles organisiert parallel drei
schauspieler und den music dome ja den
music dome dieses riesige gebäude ich
schreibe die folgenden tage dann weiter
mit dem managements bis dann endlich der
tag gekommen ist wir treffen uns mit all
den beteiligten und schauspielern um
einmal alles durch zu sprechen jede
person haben wir eigene triggerpunkte
zusammengefasst und sie den
schauspielern mitgeteilt damit genau
diese angespielt werden können und dann
war es plötzlich wirklich soweit kelly
und sandra sind beide location
angekommen und alles lief nach plan
nils und die schauspieler waren auf der
bühne platziert wird es natürlich so
dass man nämlich sieht und die crew und
ich saßen im backstage mit liveschaltung
so dass wir alles mitbekommen konnten
was auf der bühne passiert jetzt lag
alles in den händen von den
schauspielern und das ging einfach nur
noch darum details kann kopf zu die
märkte lagen blank und dann war es
wirklich soweit und regen kam auf die
bühne
red hocks genommen zu werden
das ist natürlich schon so konnten was
soll so ein bisschen innovative auch
endlich alles bisher dagewesene sagte
portlands einfach mal so ein probe am
kettling von mir wie das aussehen soll
es ein bisschen großstadtdschungel was
wir aber wir haben ganz neues design und
funktioniert ein bisschen anders
was das zweite ist die 10
super jetzt auch seinen haushalt ja sehr
gut ist nämlich auch eine version für
tiere ist aber kannst ja irgendwie so
ein bisschen ernst ja keine ahnung meint
kannst du dir vielleicht bin ich auch
nicht cool weg ohne also ganz einfach
mal so ein prof
von mir er soll sich mit dem tier genau
auskennen weil das heißt jetzt ganz
verschiedener du kannst du böse sein als
er sein kannst du kein spiel das musste
nicht mithalten zu wirklichen spielen
auch so ein bisschen von der emotionen
in diese richtung
könntest du sie hörten dass du das jetzt
wieder leben können ich sage ja zu sagen
zu toben kann also sehr innovatives
produkt deshalb jetzt haben wir so krass
ist jetzt geht ihr darum dass die ein
stopp wenn du zuerst ja genau machte
mich ja genau ich nicht sagen ich hab
jetzt schon irgendwie ein budget oder
sowas nur installiert sind und viele
fußmarsch 110 stück du willst du ganz
wohl ist wie wir entscheiden hier werden
[Musik]
nach gegriffen habe ich das ganze tier
muss man helfen
auch beziehungen sagt von dem die machen
einen posten interessiert sehr sehr dass
der rebellen al wazir in camera medien
müssten und dass die verschiedenen haben
[Musik]
wir brauchen einfach mehr von dir mal
ein bisschen wie das auspacken aber und
ausstattungen
[Gelächter]
aber ich bin kein tier
könntest du es witzig in einen anderen
kontext
bis auf gesperrt wahrscheinlich das war
meine frage warum machen wir dann hier
und da ist so solchen tier jetzt nach
arosa bin ein sachen gesagt ich hasse
zahnbürsten ich benutz einfügen und
denkt aber wünschen mögen sie
üblicherweise und sagt das ist aber
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich also ganz ehrlich
also nur kein freund oder sommer hätte
eine e mail nicht gereicht wie wir
müssen videos direkt von den kunden also
kann ich das nicht so oft zum level sein
passieren gar nicht nur die user also
wenn du jetzt immer mehr erwartet dass
ich eine zahnbürste ja auch ziemlich
viele jungen
wenn man sich heute zwar wüsste was ist
es keine zahnbürste dafür habt den pater
gewusst noch irgendetwas wissen ich bin
hier hingekommen ist nach erwartung es
ist irgendwas specialist dann kommt ihr
mit einer zahnbürste ja an
dann fragt er mich auch noch ob ich ein
placement mal in meinem leben gemacht
weil ich mache das zehn jahre sofern das
ist nicht ganz so schwierig was
irgendwie verrückt ist einfach der kunde
will dass sie alles geben das ist gar
nicht so selten ein bisschen streng
getrennt
die straße zu werfen oder so kommen
hierher gegangen zu mir ja ich bin
irgendwie zu sexy angezogen hätten
gesagt super schön solche komplimente
und dann kommen damit zu panischen
preußen gehört so jedes mal youtuber
jahr gefragt ja nach hause gemacht und
video eine stunde lang ist das thema
freunde habt ihr wirklich geglaubt dass
das jetzt das komplette video ist und
dass ich ein teil meiner allerbesten
freunde so krass hawks nehmen natürlich
das ganze nicht so wie ich es euch den
letzten minuten vorgegaukelt habe
sondern es gab einen entscheidenden
unterschied aber dafür zurück zu machen
da haben wir ziemlich an hilfen hat und
mir von der idee erzählt hat habe ich
mir zwei tage lang den kopf zerbrochen
wie ich das wohl hinbekommen könnten
teil der größten youtuber deutschlands
so krass zu verarschen baby und kelly
sind so lang auf youtube unterwegs und
ihrem management auch dass ihnen das
sofort aufgefallen wäre wenn es eine
fake agentur gewesen wir haben eine fade
kampagne oder ein fake produkten und
dann kamen wir nach ein paar tagen der
geistesblitz ich glaube jetzt einfach
weiter vor dass alles nach plan läuft
obwohl ich eigentlich die ganze planung
komplett aufzunehmen da habe ich mich
als erstes mit kelly sandra und rewe
getroffen um ihnen von der idee zu
erzählt wild und seine komplette werden
in den nächsten tagen nach köln gekommen
und hat mich angerufen mit der bitte
dass wir dich kelling um sandra
aufnehmen wie du merkst könnte das
schwierig werden wenn ich die davon
erzählen
deswegen hab ich gedacht ich drehte den
spieß einfach um und wir nehmen ihnen zu
hause weiß auch nicht woher kommt kurt
weill ich habe hier hin 300 sitzen die
solche mails bearbeiten also das werdet
ihr aufgefallen wahrscheinlich ich
glaube rechnung ohne leute gemacht die
seit jahren erfahrung damit haben uns
schon des öfteren probleme damit hat
die minis erfahrung damit haben nils
wollte euch einfällt placement und
verschlagen ihr kommt zu einem agentur
gespräch und dann passieren will das mit
nicht weiß dass ihr eingereicht weil wir
zum agentur gespräch kommen und wilde
sachen passieren von dem er nichts sonst
haben wir jetzt komplett betrunken zum
agentur gespräch kommen das ist aber
nicht so dass das ist außergewöhnlich
ist also sandra hat gesagt ich würde das
machen wir nicht dabei betrunken sein da
und sagen stimmt genau
ja ja dann kommst du hin und spielt ein
komplettes mobil und nach dir kommt
kelly mit dem großen finale und rastet
komplett und das dadurch natürlich
gucken ja wir müssen darauf achten dass
ist nicht direkt auffällt weil sandra
wie es überhaupt nicht auf eindeutig
normalzustand bei dir geht man auch
davon aus dass schon geschrieben dass
cockpit nun komplett vorgärten des
komplett übertreiben aber dass die
insassen komplett frei war es die
reaktion der meisten standen und sie als
junge zahnbürste haben der andere voll
und ganz groß gefeiert und so wird das
ablaufen und dann am ende wissen ist
ganz auf und wer jetzt denkt das video
ging durch geschickt und morgen das
erste in meinem menschen mitnimmt das
wäre absolut vertrauen
nachdem das dann alles fest war ging es
nur noch darum geht es beim ball zu
halten und ihnen glauben zu lassen dass
wirklich alles nach plan bereich bei 1
bald freuen bald verhalten im ball
player und im endeffekt hat wirklich
alles geisteskrank gut funktioniert die
jungs meldet sie mit mir im backstage
straßen waren wirklich komplett am ende
alle schützen die nerven lagen auf
grundeis als remy kelly und sandra da so
mega ausgerastet sind
[Gelächter]
obwohl wir zwar auf der bühne versteckt
und anscheinend war es so schlimm dass
er bei sandra das ding abgebrochen hat
bevor wir es richtig aufgelöst haben im
großen finale war die ganze crew auf die
bühne läuft und quasi auflösten frank
war rege und kelly sich aber null
amüsiert zeigen sieht man wie
fassungslos
jetzt ist also not haben sich das mal
genauer anguckt ist sieht so aus als
würde nils denken das ist sein leben in
diesem zeitpunkt wird damit haben wir
alles geschafft ist hat mega gut
funktioniert problem war dann nur das
fünf minuten nach dem ende nils und
seine gruppe erst gecheckt haben was
wirklich abgedunkelt ist ihr jetzt wie
das hier gelaufen ist ist das alles mit
dem durchgeplant weil es keine
möglichkeit
und im prinzip war dass die geschichte
die man in sieben tagen die komplette
wheels gruppe komplett ja freunde dieses
video war wieder eine menge aufwand
man kennt das ja mittlerweile lasse mir
leichter uhr 1 kommentar wenn ich mich
unterstützen wollt vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren damit die familie
mehr verpasst wir sehen uns ganz bald
wieder machtlos